Assuming Nicholas DiOrio's a capable of
cognitive dissonance. That's okay. If
you say so, Schleepy.
Those are just all interesting words,
aren't they? Just interesting words
worth remembering.
>> You sound like Tommy Sotomayor saying
stuff like this. I hope you kill
>> [laughter]
>> I'm genuinely disappointed in you,
Augie. Why? Good point. Good point.
>> offensive. Schleepy, good point.
Himself, awesome stuff. Awesome stuff.
We love to see it. Okay. Schleepy versus
Augie. Let's finally get into it. Oh,
jeez. I didn't realize this was an
hour-long video. Let's get into it. So,
we're going to see Schleepy's response
to Augie's response to Schleepy's video,
guys. Huge things happening. Hopefully,
they're going to argue about it on a
stream. I'm praying. I'm hoping Augie is
going to say he's willing to do it. I
know Schleepy did. Hopefully, Augie is
going to say he is. Let's take a look.
>> You know, when I released my video on
Nick DiOrio and some tweets followed up
with a second video that involved Augie
RFC, I was under the impression that
based on the response tweet from Augie
that there would be a heated beef, a
battle, a fun exciting battle. But, in
watching Augie's stream where he goes
over some of the Ethan Klein lawsuit
stuff and then covers my video, it's
become clear to me that there's not that
much tension or disagreement here. But,
I will highlight the moments that there
were disagreements and offer my
rebuttals. So, off rip, kind of what
started this entire altercation between
myself and Augie is Augie saying
objectively, it is offensive.
>> My whole take on this was I said
initially, objectively it is. If Hila
was black and Anisa was like, "Sheed,
hey man, what you doing?" That would be
hilarious because it's offensive. I
don't think Nick is suddenly disavowing
offensive humor. It's obviously a
hypocrisy argument because Anisa is a
woke scolding leftist. And the reason
why Now, Nick never verbally said that
this was a hypocrisy argument, but I
just assumed that that was the point
that he was making because Nick
regularly engages in the same type of
humor that he's calling offensive in
that clip. So, why would he be against
it if he also engages in the same
behavior? Is that not like a logical
argument? Like, that's just how I see
it, right? I know Nick. I know him
personally. I even talked to Nick. I was
like,
"I'm pretty sure you're not against edgy
humor, right?" And he was like, "Yeah,
of course not, right?" So, couple things
to unpack there. That's an interesting
sequence of statements.
At the end there, what do you hear? You
hear him say, "You know, I actually
talked to Nick and Nick said he's not
against edgy humor." So, there was some
amount of communication, which is
something that I referenced in my video
that seemed to have pissed off Augie,
okay? Augie was very mad that I would
suggest The thing is that like Augie
keeps using like the idea that, "Oh, I
know Nick. He's not against it." Like,
yeah, we know that you wouldn't expect
Nick to be against edgy humor, but the
point is that he's signaling that he is,
right? He's signaling to this new
audience that he is. suggest that him
and Nick were talking behind the scenes.
>> Or at least against some forms of it.
Okay. Turns out Augie comes clean, lets
us know. Now, I also did say, and we'll
get to that later in the video, that I
said that Augie was being dishonest. And
yet, that's a term I probably wouldn't
have used so liberally.
Maybe I would have said influenced by
his friend Nick, influenced by their
friendship, by their communications, but
also influenced by the fact that, you
know, Augie is making videos with this
guy, streams with this guy for a long
time.
Hasn't done that this year. And I don't
know how tapped in
>> two balanced, I think. prior to the
recent dramas that are going on here.
I know Augie's had some discussions
about other mistakes that DiOrio's made
this year, but I don't think Augie is
every week tapping into the Nicholas
DiOrio stream to see what he's talking
about and then make a video about it.
And I think not being as tapped into
what DiOrio's content has been like over
the last year, I think it actually makes
Augie a little bit more charitable to
DiOrio because he's not really aware of
what that content's been like. What
DiOrio's engagement with the clients has
been like. What does he criticize the
clients in a way that's not just, you
know, surface level, I don't want to
offend the people that I'm kind of
rocking with right now. So, that's where
I was coming from with this, right?
Now,
the alternative argument is that people
see this as he's posturing, he's playing
both sides, right? Where on stream he'll
say something super soy because that's
what appeals to his audience, but then
if he gets like a negative reaction to
the soy [__]
uh statement, then he'll provide like a
additional clarification. I don't really
see
>> I think Augie's getting there. I think
he's getting there. The idea is that on
stream, he's aware that he's appealing
to the H3 audience. I'm going to say
what appeals to that audience. And then,
let me go into the clipped live on
Reddit and say what appeals to the
commentary audience. contradictory to
his original argument. Yeah, I thought
Schleepy's making it sound too
conscious, too calculated there. When
it's like he goes into the segments, he
goes into his streams primed, ready to
just do the anti-Anisa, anti-Hasan,
whatever, just do his stick. So, he just
sort of say [__]
Like so often, Nick on his stream is
just sort of saying [__] And then, he
realizes how it looks, how it sounds, or
how
it fits with other positions he's got or
expressed in the past.
And he does a gay little walk back.
And I feel like a lot of people that
were like super critical of his take
here on the act and stuff are not super
familiar with the iDubbz drama in the
first place or they just don't remember
it or they don't care that much, right?
Anisa and iDubbz are woke scolding
leftists. Maybe recently they're kind of
I'm not going to waste too much time on
the oh, Anisa and iDubbz were woke
scolding leftists. In my previous video
on this subject, I feel like I pretty
well explained why I don't think that
that's like really that big of an
argument. In this like sector of the
disagreement between myself and Augie,
you have Augie's position where he's
like, "I know Nick. Nick is a guy that
is into edgy humor, is into, you know,
funny impressions. So, obviously, he was
making a hypocrisy argument." That
That's Augie's position. Is like,
"There's no way he wasn't." You know
what I mean? Naturally, that's what he
was doing. And then, my position is
I think he reflexively while in the mode
of I need to make fun of Anisa
Yeah, exactly, Kayla. Like I I said this
before when we covered it, but I'm sick
of the gesturing to hypocrisy. Show me
the hypocrisy. Show me where
this person said something that runs in
contradiction to the current actions. I
can do it for Nick. Anytime someone's
like, "Oh, prove Nick's a hypocrite." I
can go find you the clips. I can go find
you clips. I can pull up that DarkViper
clip all day,
you know?
It's very easy. So, do it for Anisa. Do
it for iDubbz. Show me the evidence.
Do it for Hasan. Show me the evidence. I
talked about that for the same reason I
made a video on this. Nick DiOrio
decided not to cover. He skipped past
the thumbnail section of Ethan Klein's
stream where Listen to what Ethan Klein
is about to read.
The thumbnail depicted Ethan performing
a Nazi salute to the Israeli flag. As
other creators have already said,
um
Noa Samsun's thumbnail just ripped the
content nuke pose and put it in his own
thumbnail. DiOrio in his original
stream, he missed this. Missed. I think
skipped. I think skipped, personally,
but missed. And so, before he uploaded
the VOD, he made
>> There's a There's another thing
happening here as well that I think
Schleepy is probably going to make a
point about at some point in this video
cuz I saw a clip in passing. I think, um
Me Me and Schleepy probably had this
argument revealed to us in the in the
same dream.
Um
but Nick is like constantly aware
that there's a chance that either Ethan
or Hila is watching his stream.
Cuz they've been in chat, they've
donated.
And when Papa Gut reacted to that I'm an
Animations thing,
uh Ethan saw it like immediately and
blew up on his Instagram story and
freaked the [__] out and brought the
hammer down on them.
Um So, Nick is like con- Nick is like
constantly aware
that, you know, his his e-daddy or his
e-daddy's wife
is like watching and that he could say
something that pisses them off or or
maybe let something go uncontested that
he shouldn't,
you know?
an edit where he goes, "Future Nick
here. Hey, future Nick here. I just
wanted to pop in and give you a bit of a
additional information on something that
I had missed while I was streaming
this." Buried an hour and 41 minutes
into the video, might I add. He explains
that he disagrees with the inclusion of
the thumbnail in the lawsuit and he he
kind of softly says, "I disagree with
the lawsuit as a whole." Like, listen to
how soft this is. As you'll I guess come
to learn by the end of this, I really
agree with this lawsuit. I really I
don't really agree with this lawsuit. I
don't really agree with this lawsuit.
Again, as you'll I guess come to learn
by the end of this,
>> I'm just so glad there are more people
saying Nick for for Nick, you know? This
is like just so cathartic seeing people
say the same [__] that he does, which is
"I really agree with that. He was Why
would he Why would I put this in? I
thought it was a good idea."
Shut the [__] up, dude. I really agree
with this lawsuit. I really don't think
it makes a lot of sense. So, so I
wouldn't go out And again, my favorite
part, I have said this many times, my
favorite part of this whole situation is
him saying, "I don't know. I don't know
what the lawyer was going for." Forget
about Ethan Klein. It's I don't know
what the lawyer was going for.
>> doing the arm to make it more look more
Nazi-esque. I don't I don't I'm not
really sure
what exactly the lawyer was going for on
this one because again, This whole idea
It feels reductive to me, like this
thinking that DiOrio can't even disagree
with them once, otherwise he'll lose
like significant like tens of thousands
of dollars, right? If he disagrees with
them a few times.
This is again, this is where I'm saying
that the perception and the information
that you take in kind of influences your
take.
Augie does not know the depth of which
DiOrio has like connected his whole
[__] [__] with the the clients. The
audience that DiOrio has that come from
the clients are always going to be more
partial to the clients than to DiOrio.
Um
like significant like tens of thousands
of dollars, right? If he disagrees with
them a few times.
This is again, this is where I'm saying
that the perception and the information
that you take in Yeah, so I don't think
that it's,
um
I I think Schleepy's off here. I think
Schleepy's
arguing with the wrong point of this.
Arguing with the wrong part of what
Augie is saying.
Augie's saying, "I don't think Nick
would lose tens of thousands of dollars
just with disagreeing disagreeing with
the clients a few times."
That's true. That's probably true.
Um
But, what's required of Nick is not just
disagreeing with the client a few times.
Nick has laid out very specific,
very firm
principles
that he claimed to hold very strongly.
Many times he's laid them out. So,
simply disagreeing a couple of times,
saying in passing, "I don't think Ethan
should have used save a fox like that."
Or some [__] whatever he said. Don't
think he even said that. I think he just
said, "I disagreed with that."
Um
that's not enough. That's not enough.
Nick either needs to explain why there
is a massive change in his principles
and cop to that.
Or
he needs to change his positions
massively.
It is not enough to simply disagree a
couple of times.
We can run down all the clips from
grandstanding about DarkViper, about the
way Ethan used Etika's death. You know,
there are just a million different
parallels for [__] that he has
you know,
harshly condemned in the past, but now
gives a total free pass to.
kind of influences your take.
Augie does not know the depth of which
Diiorio has like connected his whole
[__] [__] with the the clients. The
audience that Diiorio has that come from
the clients are always going to be more
partial to the clients than to Diiorio.
And if Diiorio wants to keep those
people around, he cannot have a moment
that causes Ethan to be like, "I don't
[__] with Diiorio anymore."
>> If Diiorio tonight heel turned and
decided, "You know what? [__] you." This
is This take made no sense. Ethan, he
would get a lot of backlash, but
I almost feel like the viewers like a
heel turn in a lot of different ways.
Like I've seen like a lot of streamers
in the past do Viewers would have so
much cognitive dissonance over the last
year worth of content. I don't know who
the [__] who's going to be like, "Oh,
yeah, awesome shit." You know? Assuming
Nicholas Diiorio viewers are capable of
cognitive dissonance. That's all right.
If If you say so. If you say so, Sleepy.
Yet to be seen.
No, awesome [__] Diiorio. The H3
audience drops him like that
immediately. So, audience cut in half.
Anyone with a brain is like asking
themselves why this didn't happen
sooner. And then maybe you got like 700
left that are like diehards for Diiorio,
which I mean that's respectable.
>> with this type of [__] Where it's like,
"Yeah, they'll obviously lose a
significant portion of their audience
and maybe even some money, but like the
overall support will still be there." I
mean, how many times has Destiny cut off
like massive chunks of his audience when
he went after Hasan? Or when he decided
that, "You know what? [__] the com- This
is the thing that like when was Destiny
ever an orbiter? When was Destiny
orbiting a bigger content creator?
I don't know if that's ever happened.
Maybe I'm like wrong on the history of
Destiny. Typically, people would orbit
him. I guess in that case you could you
could point to Vaush being like a good
example of somebody who sprouted their
own career after orbiting him. Maybe
Diiorio is like the next Vaush, you
know? Maybe Nah. engage with the commies
anymore and stuff like that, right? Like
hasn't Destiny axed his audience in half
like multiple times throughout his
entire career? And obviously he's been
financially and like relevance-wise fine
from that. Uh Chet gave kind of a
[__] response when I was watching
what he said. It It was like basically
saying that, "Oh, Destiny's like a
special case." I I don't think Destiny's
a special case at all. I think that's
like
just like a delusion. The only way in
which Destiny's a special case is that
he's like totally shameless.
He's just like a you know, degenerate
pervert with no shame.
Like it is true that obviously, you
know, Chet was saying he's like got a
charisma to him and people getting
pissed off. That's obviously true to an
extent like he does have a charisma you
have to be to keep an audience.
Um
but that's not why he's able to survive
stuff like he is. It's just cuz he's
apart of that with
no shame.
Uh he will just stream through anything.
And that's basically
90% of the battle is just not taking
your foot off the gas.
you know.
So, the idea that if Diiorio were to
criticize Ethan Klein or laugh at any of
his joke, like even just subtly, right?
It does kind of I don't buy that fully.
>> I mean, there is like a decent amount of
history of Ethan being like extremely
vindictive and having thin skin. So, I
think in Diiorio's position having a
healthy amount of fear is probably the
best case scenario if you're trying to
ride this H3 coattail. Wait, this
actually Oh, that's a Or when he decided
to message a minor. I mean, yeah, that's
true, right? Like even doing that didn't
lose Destiny a significant amount of his
audience, clearly.
I don't think the YouTube viewer cares
that much at the end of the day. You
know, I mean, Ethan or sorry, Nick is
already losing a significant portion
of his audience right now to H3 simply
because H3 does a night show now
streaming over Diiorio's time slot. I
feel like he would lose more just from
H3 streaming over him than Nick would if
he just criticized
uh Ethan once or twice or laughed at any
of his joke. I mean, he has Okay, well,
if that's the case, then why hasn't he
done it? Like like let's just, you know,
why hasn't he done it? There's a reason
he hasn't done it. Wasn't Diiorio the
guy that like cut off all of his
friends? He cut off Bo Black. He cut off
Flamenco, okay? He takes people out to
pasture. Like Augie is writing this
fanfic that like Diiorio can cut off the
audience and suffer no consequence. Or
maybe suffer a minor viewer loss, but
then eventually bounce back. Why hasn't
he done it then? Like if it's so easy,
if it's something that he could totally
do, why hasn't he done it? Maybe if we
evaluate his actions and look at the
incentives, we can go, "Mm, maybe he's
not doing it because he's in a good
position right now financially. Maybe
he's not doing it because he knows that
if he does overstep a line with the
clients, that he will get cut out."
>> one of the easiest That's true. Yeah,
yeah. So, this is the point that I was
saying earlier. That is true. That is
true. I don't think Nick would like
totally lose his entire audience by
going against them, but he's worried
about getting cut out by them.
overstep a line with the clients that he
>> He's also worried about what happens if
he makes an enemy of them and they come
down on him.
will get cut out. I mean, one of the
easiest examples is what happened with
Papa Gut. Papa Gut found himself
reacting to the legend of Ethan Klein.
It was a little animation. It's very
funny, but obviously, you know, it
levied some criticisms at Ethan. It kind
of makes him look like a cracked out
schizo. So, Ethan Klein does what he
does best and he gets on his Instagram
story and starts complaining. If Papa
Gut is falling for shallow snark bait,
then I'm screwed. Now, this is the
screenshot that Ethan Klein posted and
this is the topic that Papa Gut was
discussing. It was regarding the clips
channel and Trisha Paytas wanting a cut.
person I worked with.
You know, I [snorts] will say something
cuz I I like Ethan, you know. Got to
establish that so I can say something
crude about him and sounds like it has
credibility.
>> [laughter]
>> Listen to how nice he's being just to
start. I like Ethan.
I want to make sure that people know I
like Ethan before I say a criticism.
>> [gasps]
>> Nah, but I I like Ethan, but I saw this
like weird clip where
uh Ethan was talking about I guess more
recently or maybe it's out of context
where like he they make a lot of money
from the the show uh the clips channel.
And then he it does a flashback to where
he where uh Trisha Paytas was like, "I
want fi- I want some of the clips
channel money." And he's like, "It's not
that much. Like don't worry about it."
And it's so funny because like um why
lie about that?
You know?
I can't find it.
But it's like why lie about that? Like
why not just be like, "Listen, I'm
giving you" He was already giving her
50% of the memberships for the whole
channel, which considering they had like
two other podcast days, was quite
generous. And 45% of the revenue from
those episodes. I think that that's fair
and I think it's fair for him to make
more money cuz he's producing the show.
It's his entire infrastructure. He put
up the money to start the show. He has
an entire studio infrastructure. So, the
weird thing to me is like why why lie?
Like it's what he's talking about his
clips channel. That's my understanding.
Why lie about that? It's like it's
almost seems like he just thinks
Trisha's stupid. So, he's just like,
"No, no, it's not a lot of money. Shut
up."
Valid?
Military target? I disagree.
So, again, like he's levying a criticism
here. He's saying, you know, why would
you lie about the clips channel not
making a lot of money? And Ethan can't
just let that go without a response.
Like there's no need to respond to
something this minor. Like this is not
uh uh a clip that needs to be addressed.
But Ethan goes on his Instagram story
and says, "Before Frenemies, when we
were doing the show once per week, our
highlights channel was getting 30 to 50
million monthly views. While the podcast
was getting 5 to 7 million. That was the
first 3 years of the podcast before I
ever mentioned Trisha. The algorithm
changed to throttle highlight channels
before Frenemies. Go sort by most
popular videos on the highlight channel
and you'll see. Why lie about something
like that,  ? That's a
question for snark. Papa Gut watched
this video, offered an opinion that
Ethan Klein couldn't stomach. So, Ethan
posted a story about it. That Instagram
story does impact
>> You don't You don't win Instagram story,
do you, Nick? You don't win You don't
get an Instagram story from Ethan, do
you, Nick?
Dude, it's just so [__] embarrassing.
It is actually so [__] embarrassing.
>> audience will view Papa Gut going
forward. Like listen to the language
he's using. If Papa Gut is falling
>> he uses Instagram is cuz he got ran off
of Twitter, right? He He was sick of
everyone calling him a zogbot in all of
his [__]
Twitter replies. So, he got ran off.
>> the shallow snark bait, then I'm
screwed.
>> Hey, look at these tweets. These are
tweets. credibly important to be aware
of what Ethan Klein thinks.
>> Nobody uses Instagram stories like this
other than Ethan. Now, let's watch let's
watch Nicholas Diiorio condemn Ethan
Klein for pushing the snark aspect of
the story when really snark had not that
much to do with this woman committing
suicide. fox person
uh that that whole suicide situation. I
was like, "I don't think this is a snark
issue." I thought it right away before
anyone said it. And I saw a lot of
people on Twitter
>> you weren't in on that? I saw a lot of
people who just immediately assumed I
think even even Ethan to an extent kind
of a even Ethan to an extent.
>> So, you know what I You know what I did?
I instantly went and I looked at uh the
subreddit and how many posts were there
and they were all from like one person
and it was like 10. I was like, "Okay,
whatever." Yeah, a lot of people were
[__] really mad about that.
>> I I don't mean to be mean. I just feel
like like
like I I think that Anything to say
about Ethan being completely wrong on
that, Diiorio? Anything? I don't even
know if that's the subreddit
>> the point where like there's so much
[__] us versus them mentality that's
popping up from people to the point
where like we've stopped researching
[__] And I think that's like I think
it's a really dangerous place to be in
if you can't Google the name of the
subreddit before you go out there and
start saying they're killing people.
Okay, who was saying that? Who exactly
was saying that, DiOrio? Yeah.
Um
Yeah, there is a lot of us versus them
and I think
>> Anyways, point is this is the
condemnation that Augie is pointing to.
Like look, he disagreed with Ethan one
time. Absolutely heartbreaking. The
snark subreddit is already private and
the mods accounts erased. Ethan was very
clearly trying to make her suit
you know, result of the snark subreddit.
And here's what Dan Saltman had to say
about that.
>> And I looked at the subreddit and how
many posts were there and they're all
from like one person and it was like 10.
And I was like, okay, whatever.
Yeah, a lot of people were [__]
really mad about that.
>> I I don't So like it's it's clear that
that subreddit really did not have any
impact on the situation, minor at best.
And Ethan, on the flip side, is running
with it like look at what snark does to
people. Guys, a lot of people were
really mad about that.
Why would you be so mad about
Ethan Klein using someone's death for
his own gain, using someone's suicide
for his own gain? The segment that
bothered me most in this video was the
huge chunk dedicated to the creator
Etika. First of all, I'd like to
reiterate that Keemstar's stance on
mental health from this time period was
[__] appalling. If you don't believe
me, look no further than the three sips
of beer tweet that's become quite the
meme recently.
>> I think Keemstar's handling of the
situation is definitely open to
criticism and should be criticized. In
fact, some of this segment does that
excellently.
>> For example, the fact that Keemstar
posted a mental hospital he was
attending to his millions of followers
in 2018 was absurd. And interviewing him
when he got out of the mental hospital
in 2019 was clearly a big mistake on
Keemstar's part. The part that I and
most other social media influencers had
an issue with was the insinuation that
Ethan clearly made about Keemstar
killing Etika.
>> He knew he would get lots of views and
he did with great cost to Etika.
Keemstar's greatest moment comes when he
asked Etika [music] in a manic state,
"Why doesn't he just jump off a cliff?"
You really think about it, then why
live? Just jump off a cliff. Just jump
off a cliff. If it's just a simulation,
who cares? Of course, hypothetical, but
it is quite a coincidence when you
consider [music] that only 51 days later
that very same YouTuber jumped off a
bridge to his death.
>> sure that Ethan will brush this entire
allegation off as simply speculation
based on his track record of recent
replies, there's a good reason why so
many people walked away from the video
thinking that was his underlying
intention. It also doesn't help that
very next clip showcases FouseyTube and
a very select line was chosen out of all
the possible clips that would be
applicable to the mental health
argument. FouseyTube is another YouTuber
who is a frequent target of Keemstar's.
He also suffered a manic break and here
he is talking directly to Keemstar. Hey,
I'm just telling you as a man at 28
years old what I feel. You made me want
to commit suicide last year. I wanted to
kill myself because of all the attention
you gave me. I rewatched videos going
viral after the attention you gave me
now of you saying, "Fousey is the
biggest piece of [__] egotistical
[__] on this earth."
I HAVE BIPOLAR AND DEPRESSION. THAT'S
WHAT YOU PUT INTO MY HEAD, MADE ME WANT
TO KILL MYSELF. IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR AN
EXPLANATION OR ANY added context, there
is none. That's all in another video. He
literally just plays a clip of Fousey
screaming, "Keemstar makes me want to
kill myself" following the Etika story
and then nonchalantly moves on to the
next subject.
>> What you put into my head MADE ME WANT
TO KILL MYSELF. THAT'S TERRIBLE.
But ladies and gentlemen, I am here to
tell you that Ethan Klein is a liar.
This stuff makes me sick for a multitude
of reasons. Naturally, the context
that's missing is a good place to start.
Notably omitted from the video is the
statement delivered by Etika's own
mother. She stepped up to defend
Keemstar when he was initially being
blamed stating that Keemstar is not
responsible for Etika's passing and she
Oh, almost like Sabre Spark's husband
saying that
uh it it was because of
real life people that owned other that
were part of other fox sanctuaries. It's
almost almost like that. also gave
Keemstar some pretty good advice down
there at the bottom. There's also the
messages from Etika's girlfriend sharing
the same sentiment from both before and
again after the content nuke dropped.
Oh, almost like that. Same thing that I
just said. The part that really [__]
annoys me. Etika's ex-girlfriend Alex
was trashed on social media for sharing
her opinion in defense of Keemstar to
the point where she felt forced to
either delete the tweets and private her
account or face an oncoming hate mob.
>> Imagine that that one didn't exactly
happen. ex-boyfriend dies tragically
nearly a year ago after a successful
[__] suicide attempt and you now have
to be subjected to prepubescent pieces
of [__] who watched one guy's YouTube
video and feel the need to tell you that
you're wrong about why he killed
himself. Imagine a hate mob telling this
girl that she's not grieving correctly.
Imagine [__] arguing with someone who
would know saying that Keemstar did
reach out to Etika behind the scenes and
your response is to send her some
screenshots of tweets that people were
spamming all over the website that
night. Then another close personal
friend of Etika came out in complete
support of Ethan. Now this is filed into
inadvertently pitting the loved ones of
Etika against each other. Now look, I
know this wasn't Ethan's goal, but Jesus
[__] Christ, is this fair to anyone?
Why the [__] would you make Etika the
focal point of your video that was
designed to get back at Keemstar for
accusing you of pocketing money from the
game Payday 2. Why does this dude's
legacy need to be subjected to this? Why
does this dude's tragic suicide need to
be weaponized and debated on a year
later in YouTube drama exposed video?
This just feels like a cop-out because
he's gone. He's unable to speak for
himself. Etika is unable to interject
and let people know what he was feeling
or pick a side. It's an allegation that
h3h3 felt comfortable to walk right up
to the door with because Etika's not
here to tell him that's not true and
nobody knows exactly what was going
through Etika's mind.
>> out, "Etika fans are tweeting Ooh, so
those are just all interesting words,
aren't they? Just interesting words
worth remembering. People are killing
themselves over snark. Point is Augie is
like misremembering what happens. DiOrio
did not give a firm condemnation of
Ethan. That's just not what happened. I
don't I don't know, is it? Is it them
sperging out? Like it doesn't feel like
that.
>> so embarrassing. You guys are are these
edgelords yourselves and you're like,
"Well, well they're supposed to be woke
scolding like they're being hypocrites."
Okay, dude. Okay, who gives a [__] Like
I really really this is this is your
issue? Like Augie's in my comments
saying that he's I don't care cuz I'm
racist, but that's how people see it.
Pointing out that something is offensive
doesn't mean that you find it
problematic. Dude. Like
>> [laughter]
>> it's such a funny thing to tweet, "I
don't care because I'm racist."
Again, he clearly found it problematic
and he clearly
>> Wait, but why not respond to the
argument though? Like dude. Again, he
clearly found it problematic. But hold
on.
So I think okay. I think me saying he
clearly found it problematic is a bit
confusing because it does sound like I'm
saying he personally finds it
problematic. I think what I'm trying to
say
Let me give myself the benefit of the
>> I think virtue signaling has become mad
overused, you know? Like just saying
like I'm racist or whatever, it's just
mad overused. [laughter]
I think what I'm trying to say is that
in that moment he's reacting based on
the situation, based on he's covering
Anisa and there's a there's a way that
he needs to cover Anisa. He needs to be
negative towards Anisa. And when he
reacts, he kind of soys out and says not
only is that offensive, right?
That's like
that's him kind of saying this is kind
of problematic. Now, does he actually
believe it's problematic? I think
everybody here seems to agree that no,
he does his own offensive humor. The
whole point is that he was reacting to
it on the fly and his snap reaction was,
"Oh, this is offensive. This is
problematic." My read of that, I've
already kind of explained, he's going to
be partial towards Ethan Klein and he's
going to be anti-Anisa. That's the
incentive of that direction. Augie's
read is that he's making a hypocrisy
argument when he's saying that it's
offensive. Does he respond to the
argument? Can you point out that
something is offensive without you
finding it offensive? Yes, you can point
out that something is offensive without
finding it offensive. My point is why is
DiOrio calling this offensive? What what
is causing him to do that? Why is his
snap reaction to call this offensive?
>> comments saying that he's I don't care
cuz I'm racist, but that's how people
see it. Pointing out that something is
offensive doesn't mean that you find it
problematic. Dude. Again, he clearly
found it problematic. It's like dude,
come on, just trust me, bro. Why?
problematic. Yeah, in fairness I in
fairness I don't think I broke that
point down accurately or properly. So
I'll give him that. And he clearly did
not think about the hypocrisy argument
when he played this clip.
>> I'm a big fan The second half of that I
I'm banging because he wasn't thinking
about the hypocrisy thing, but I should
have explained
a lot better what I meant by oh, he
clearly found that problematic. He found
it problematic in so far as a reaction
when he's making Anisa content. But but
does he find it problematic personally?
Like probably not. And if Nicholas
DiOrio, what can I say? You do your
research.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know. Not only is that
offensive, it's also bad. Like it's a
Again, and we play the entire thing. So
he just replays the clip, but it's like
can you have that position? Not once in
this [__]
Yes, yes, you can have that position.
clip was he thinking this is kind of
hypocritical? He wasn't even thinking
about that. It's a post
This hypo the hypocritical point I'm
killing him on, but the the fact that I
didn't go and explain that problematic
part properly, that that's a bit of an L
on my part.
>> rationalization. So we should be
throwing that whole hypocrisy argument
out to begin with. But I'm only engaging
with it because of you, Augie, because
you've decided to double down and
because you're trying to defend your boy
and I get it. That's your homie, you're
trying to be a good friend, but do not
let this guy make you You sound like
Tommy C when you say [__] like that. I
hope you kill Augie.
>> [laughter]
>> That's awesome.
That's awesome.
>> [laughter]
>> be throwing that whole hypocrisy
argument out to begin with. But I'm only
engaging with it because of you, Augie,
because you've [laughter] decided to
double down and because you're trying to
defend your boy and I get it. That's
your homie, you're trying to be a good
friend, but do not let this guy make you
You sound like Tommy C when you say [__]
like that. I hope you kill Augie. I hope
you Okay, I'm joking, but please do not
ever compare me to Tommy C ever again.
What kind of [__] [__] you. [__] you.
What a terrible thing to [laughter] say
to someone. I hear the same when when
Slanderly makes his point right here,
all I hear is Tommy C. It's the same
[__] It's like you can never have an
opinion of your own, you're only doing
it for some ulterior motive because
That wasn't my point. It wasn't ulterior
motive. Like obviously you have your
opinion. I'm just saying, you know, I
think you're trying to be a a good guy.
I think you're trying to be a homie.
That's what I was trying to give you an
out, bro. I was throwing you a bone. And
you're out here calling me Tommy C for
for throwing you a bone?
For being a nice guy? I'm Tommy C?
>> a good friend, isn't he, guys? Isn't
Augie such a good friend? I'm addicted
to alcohol? I got a [__] brain
missing? That's one thing you can always
say about Augie. Why would you Why would
you ever say that? Why would you call me
a bone like that? What the [__] wrong
with you?
>> Cuz you're trying to back up your boy,
you're trying to stay tight with DiOrio,
you're trying to do this for the No, not
stay tight. I'm just saying you're being
a good friend, man. Oh my god.
>> this reason. You're trying to play the
the some, you know, background political
game and it's like
how about I just have a [__] opinion?
You have an opinion and you're being a
good friend. Can Can that Can these
things not exist at the same time?
How about I just looked at the argument
that you're making and I have a
different side of it. That's it. You
know? [__] your side, Augie. Your side's
[__] [__] you. Doesn't have to be
like some ulterior motive. Why can't I
Why am I the only person that can have
an ulterior motive here? You know, it's
always got to be like I'm doing
something because I have to protect my
friend, but it's never you're
incentivized to view DeOro in the most
bad faith way possible. I'm not saying
he's being bad faith, but I'm just
saying like you're incentivized to look
at DeOro Look at this guy calling me bad
faith.
>> DeOro in the most bad faith way possible
because it's content for you or
something. That's true. It is content
for me. It is. That's fair. But I also
don't agree with DeOro, right? I'm not
just doing this because selfishly I'm
trying to make some money, okay? I also
just like genuinely have like
disagreements with this person, and and
I think that what they've been doing is
like embarrassing, and I look at the
person and the content and the ideas and
the opinions that this person held like
3 4 years ago, and I compare them to the
person that exists today, and I'm like,
what caused this like change? And it's
very clear to me, and I think it's my
it's you know, when you see something
like that, you want to call it out, and
you want to talk about it. Like that's
what commentary is all about.
>> a valid argument. Like you can never
have any ulterior motive here. It's
always going to be like I I'm the one
with the ulterior motive. You know?
Uh yeah, like I'm not trying to say that
he had I I mean, I guess that's what it
comes off of. Like that's what like when
I say, "Oh, you're just trying to be a
good friend." Like it sounds like, "Oh,
you have ulterior motives." But it's not
what I'm trying to say. I'm I'm trying
to give him an out. I'm trying to say,
"Listen, you said something that I
thought was [__] and um
I think you just, you know, you're being
you're being a good friend, and maybe
you you stuck yourself out a bit further
than you needed to, you know?
Yeah, I mean, that is the thing. Augie
has sort of said like, you know, he does
he obviously does have a bias towards
his friends. Obviously, everyone does to
an extent, but Augie has been
quite um
Yeah, there was that whole Brandon
Buckingham thing,
you know, with the with the doxing
Turkish Tom's
accuser or whatever.
He's just like, "Well, yeah, when my
friends do something bad to people that
have [__] them over, I think that's
awesome." So, okay.
Make you think that he was doing this
for any other reason than he was
defending Ethan Klein's honor. True.
>> Because that's what it was. He's not
allowed to find that funny. In that
moment
>> He's not allowed to find it funny. He's
he's I don't think he is. I don't think
he is. I think the Papa Gut um example
is a very good example where I
you know, you you you you lean a little
bit too much to one direction, Ethan
Klein gets wind of it, and he posts a
Instagram story about you.
>> It just seems like so insane to me,
right? It's like he's never he's
>> insane. Augie, it is insane. That's why
I'm talking about it. That's why it's so
crazy to me.
>> joke, he loses $10,000 a month.
Does he? Yeah, kind of. Yeah, he does,
kind of.
>> [laughter]
>> Maybe, I guess. I don't see it that way.
If he laugh maybe you guess. That's
we're we're moving him. We're moving
him.
>> [laughter]
>> We're moving him to the If he thinks
that's a really good impression,
actually, his audience will tear him
apart. He's not allowed to find what
Anisa is saying funny, and he definitely
can't laugh at Anisa impersonating Ethan
Klein. And Augie, let me be clear.
Forget about this clipped live uh post
that he's doing. I'm genuinely
disappointed in you, Augie. Why?
Why are you genuinely disappointed? It's
like you hear a take that does you don't
agree with, you're like, "I can't
believe this." doing the post talk
rationalization. There is no way, and we
played the full 2 minutes, there is no
way that in the clip itself you got the
impression that DeOro was talking about
a hypocrisy argument. You only got that
from what he said in the clip live, but
you did not get that from his stream
because he did not say that, and he
wasn't thinking it. He said that Good
point. Good point. It was offensive for
completely different reason.
Shaping good point in himself. Awesome
stuff. Awesome stuff. We love to see it.
>> Again, I just used my brain. You know, I
just used my brain. I just heard him say
that. I'm like, True. True. True.
>> [laughter]
>> But yeah, using your brain, that's the
problem though. Is that like I thought
so when I saw Augie's take, I thought he
was basing it off of the clip live,
which apparently is not the case.
Apparently, he just came to that
conclusion that the hypocrisy argument
was like by default what DeOro was
doing. He came to that conclusion on his
own, which makes it even more confusing
to me. Like again, I can I can admit
that it is plausible that it was a
hypocrisy argument. I don't think it's
likely. I don't think it's likely at
all. man was like anti-edgy content
while also hosting a show called Rape
Review.
Right?
>> It's not that he's anti-edgy content.
It's that he's anti-Anisa
saying something funny or negative
towards Ela. He's got to offer that
reaction. That's That's what I'm saying.
That's why that reflex comes in. If
DeOro just came out and was like, "This
is offensive. It's too far. It's [__]
up. It's wrong."
I mean, that would be like a lyrics
moment almost, you know?
Yeah, no, I don't think that that's
what's going to happen there.
>> That would be like a tipster moment.
It'd be a disaster, right?
All I'm saying is is that I don't view
DeOro as somebody that's now anti-edgy
humor. If if Neither do I, man. Neither
do I. That's not my point.
>> was anti-edgy humor, Although again, I
did argue the problematic point poorly,
and I think that that's kind of why
Augie's going down this road now. I
would rate him.
If DeOro came out, he was like,
"This [__] sucks. It's too far. It's
wrong." Okay, I would molest him
every day. I would be fully on board
with it, right?
But I just don't see that as his new
position. The worst thing I think he
could say about this clip is that he was
virtue signaling.
Like he subconsciously was like
think that it's offensive to appeal to
his audience. If that's what your
argument is or whatever, fair enough, I
guess. Yeah, that's that's my argument.
Thanks. Thank you. Appreciate it. Thank
you. I mean, it goes a little bit
further than that. It's not just the
audience. Like obviously, the audience
is part of it. It's a big part of it. I
don't want Anisa to sound funny to the
audience, but also it's it's that
looming threat that Ethan Klein is like
>> [laughter]
>> Like DeOro does not want Ethan to pull
the plug, okay? And I think that that
influences a lot of the things that
DeOro says. Like he subconsciously was
like
think that it's offensive to appeal to
his audience. If that's what your
argument is or whatever, fair enough, I
guess. But
I I just don't see this as like that big
of a [__] deal. So yeah, like I said,
I don't agree with what Augie said here.
I think I mean, obviously, I don't agree
with what Nick said. I don't The
individual instance is not a big deal,
but that is just yet another point. It
is just yet another example. I think
Nick is I think Nick's making it up as
he goes along. I think Nick knows he's a
[__] dead man walking, channel wise,
of course. Like let me be clear, channel
wise.
True. I still agree. Dead man walking.
Like I said before, I'm completely
shocked and utterly surprised that he
even reacted to Anisa doing the
impression because everybody knew there
was no positive easy way for him to get
out of that. And I want to point out
some comments that I agree with here.
Jay Stock goes, "Is there more to the
clip that's cut off that makes it
clearly a hypocrisy argument?" The
Reddit comment. So, after the fact, he
said something different. Again, I don't
see how the Reddit comment like is
different or devalidates what he said on
stream. Different or devalidate? No, the
point is the point is your take is that
he was making a hypocrisy argument.
Your take is that he was making a
hypocrisy argument, and my take is that
he just said that reflexively, okay?
So, when Jay Stock goes, "Is there more
to the clip that's cut off that makes it
clearly a hypocrisy argument?" And then
confusing says, "The Reddit comment. So,
after the fact, he said something
different." What everyone is trying to
say here is that the clip does not
possess any hallmarks of a hypocrisy
argument, but the Reddit comment
explains that it was a hypocrisy
argument, and you've taken that side as
well. Apparently, without reading the
Reddit comment. That's you know, you've
come to that conclusion naturally on
your own, apparently.
But that's that's why I'm bringing it
up. Is that like nobody the video itself
does not play as a hypocrisy argument.
>> Nick hasn't found a new eight idea. I
don't even know who it would be. Would
he just go back to Keemstar?
Go back to Keemstar, become a local live
host like Tommy C.
The clip itself, he is clearly not
talking about hypocrisy. Not Chronic
Sonic says, "I thought you guys were
dying for Ian and Anisa to do edgy humor
again. I'm all for it." Augie goes, "I'm
all for it regardless of how
hypocritical they look. It's so [__]
soy. You guys are hypocrites. You guys
You guys said that you're done with the
edgy stuff, and now you're being edgy
again. You [__] Like don't [__] piss
your pants over this shit." And here's
the other thing. There's no It's a valid
point though. Oh, real like Well, valid
like
it it bothers me because valid point
maybe for Augie to make, maybe. I I
still think it's soy,
>> Well, but he can't be a media guy. It's
not Again, my whole issue is that DeOro
wasn't making that point. DeOro was just
reacting naturally. DeOro's natural
reaction to
>> he's never had a following for media
takes.
to Anisa.
>> Right, he he can't make media content.
He has a drama channel. impersonating
>> So, if I like, you know, I'll talk about
movies on stream sometimes, but if I
tried to actually just start posting
movie reviews on my channel, it would be
[__] hating Ela is to say it's
offensive and bad, and then later on say
that, "Oh, that was just a hypocrisy
argument that I was making." When the
video itself does not show that. It just
it just shows him like reacting and
saying, "Ooh, that's offensive." If you
guys want to play a drinking game
that'll kill you if you're watching this
video, uh take a shot every time I say
hypocrisy. hallmarks of anti-Semitism
here, right? Like uh maybe if Anisa did
oy vey and the merchant hands, you know
what I mean? Uh listen, those aren't
like stereotypical offensive things to
do that are considered anti-Semitic,
right? She wasn't doing them. She was
clearly impersonating Ela, not Israelis
as a whole, and not Jews. Definitely not
Jews. Listen, Augie, I I get it, you
know, it's your buddy, but I'm telling
you get off this DeOro train. I know
he's in the the Discord chats. I know
he's in the group chat saying, "This
sleepy guy, we got to do something about
this." If you gen
>> [laughter]
>> Uh no.
>> humanly are watching that clip and
thinking, "Oh, he's he's talking about
hypocrisy. Oh, he's he's he's making an
argument here." You've lost the plot. I
don't I don't believe that you've lost
the plot. Like I said, I think you're
being a good friend. I think you saw
what he said in clip live. I'm sure he
sent you some texts, and you threw out a
tweet that frankly, I I don't agree
with. I think it's a bit of a silly
take, but it is what it is. Anyways,
ladies and gents, if you enjoyed today's
video, and you want to see more like it,
leave a like, comment, and subscribe,
and I'll see you in the next Okay, so
there's some points in there. I don't
agree with everything like that though,
and it's like, "Augie, you need to get
off the DeOro train. It's crazy." I
don't know. It's true. Get off the DeOro
train.
Get off.
All all What's the opposite of all
aboard?
Evacuate. Evacuate. [laughter]
No, dude. I'm not on the Diorio train.
I do completely separate [__] from him.
It's like I just happen to agree. Now, I
will say to be fair Augie obviously
lying. They're talking about Sleepy day
and night. Yeah. I totally did not need
to get myself into this conversation
because obviously you look gay defending
a friend or you even just talk about
this at all or just defending yourself
even. You look gay. Then I need Which is
why I was like, you know what? Good for
you. You're defending your friend. And
then you go, "You're just like Tommy C.
You think I can't have any opinions of
my own. [__] you." get involved in this
conversation I just kind of did or
whatever cuz, you know, I just had a I
had an opinion. I dared to have an
opinion.
But yeah, I mean that's just how I see
it. So, I don't I don't know.
Let's take a look at what uh So,
WaugieRFC for uh following up 3 weeks
later and and still reacting to the
video and the tweets and stuff.
WaugieRFC, I think
as you can see, it seems like he's a lot
more closer to the um
I don't want to say anti-Diorio, but
like Yeah, I guess that's what it is,
right? I I think he's a lot more closer
to the non-Diorio stuff now than he was
before. I also think on the flip side
he's kind of got to defend his takes cuz
what what's he going to do? Just [__]
[__] out? No. Ultimately, I think the
thing I took most issue with was him
comparing me to Tommy C. I I think that
was a really [__] up thing of him to
do to me. I'm expecting an apology at
some point, okay? Augie, if I if I ever
meet you, I will be I will we will be I
will be hostile until you apologize for
comparing me to Tommy C. [__] you.
Anyhow, ladies and gentlemen
Wow.
Heavy stuff, guys.
Jesus. Hour long video there. I didn't
realize it was just like a straight-up
reaction, to be honest.
I thought it was like a
more traditional video.
But there you go. Go go support Sleepy,
[music] as always.